alors musique ça marche pour charles et
son équipe pas question de se relâcher
musicaux cas ici et lumière ici hockey
le metteur en scène de 1900 s'assure que
tout est en place pour le final après
trois week-ends de représentation
c'est la satisfaction pour moi c'est
d'abord là le grand plaisir de voir la
joie que les uns et les autres prennent
à faire vivre ce rêve la place que
chacun a pu prendre dans se révélent
appropriée en faire son rêve d'iguane
est un peu devenu le château des rêves
les rêves de chacun et chacune des
participants et c'est là que réside
véritablement le succès 15h30 le public
arrive certains comme julien viennent
pour la deuxième fois c'était super
franchement j'ai adoré qu'est ce qui
t'as plus les costumes le décor
l'ambiance
est
à l'initiative de ce voyage dans le
temps jean louis rey mieux le
propriétaire du château de digoine ne
tarit pas d'éloges pour les bénévoles
qui ont participé à l' aventure vous
rendez compte que plus de 450 bénévoles
ont répété un rôle alors qu'il n'avait
jamais joué il n'avait jamais fait de
théâtre de leur vie
c'est un triomphe
plus de 14 mille tickets vendus
quelque chose d'absolument inattendue
les comédiens eux espèrent tous
renouvelés laventure le plus vite
possible
c'est une expérience magnifique on a
rencontré plein de gens qu'on ne
connaissait ni en blanc et en noir on se
tutoie tous on se connaît tous ces
magnifiques il va y avoir un grand
manque je pense à partir de ce soir
l'équipe de 1900 se projette maintenant
vers le futur une nouvelle saison est
d'ores et déjà prévue pour l'année
prochaine et cette fois sur quatre
week-ends
[Applaudissements]